welcome back to the david pakman show i
am fair and cousins from ring of fire
sitting in for david pakman this week
and if you've enjoyed me feel free
please subscribe to the ring of fire
podcast go to rofpodcast.com
and subscribe to our youtube channel at
youtube.com slash the ring of fire or
youtube.com slash farron balanced
let's get right back into the news we've
got a lot of republican infighting and
of course some more news from the
january 6 select committee
so let's jump in first and foremost
steve bannon
steve bannon is unhappy with mitch
mcconnell
because donald trump is unhappy with
mitch mcconnell as we all know donald
trump has been engaged in a months-long
battle with mitch mcconnell that has
kind of had some highs and some lows and
trump trying out his new nickname for
him the old broken crow the
old crow the broken old crow a lot of
different iterations he hasn't quite
settled on one yet but either way he's
mad at mitch mcconnell
and of course he is encouraging
republicans to oust him from his
leadership position
so this past friday on his war room show
steve bannon joined in and attacked
mitch mcconnell for what he sees as a
betrayal
of donald trump
here's what bannon said
he is a direct challenge to president
trump and trump is trying to lead this
country through these horrible times
mitch mcconnell that dirt bag right
there
gave the biden regime two and a half
trillion to fund their madness
their madness
these are horrible times he says
and we're funding madness
huh
you know what really gets me about that
before i get into the really the heart
of the argument here is what the hell
are they talking about horrible times
they what exactly are conservatives so
mad about right now other than losing
the 2020 election
what about their lives has changed
since joe biden came along
right we haven't had lockdowns
we have vaccines readily available we're
on the verge of approving an actual
coveted treatment so you can't complain
about the covet stuff
he hasn't changed your taxes so you
can't complain about that so what
exactly
are conservatives angry about with the
biden administration honest to god i
want an answer to that i want a real
legitimate answer
from conservatives
about what you're so mad about from this
administration and i think that is a
question
we should be asking of them on a regular
basis why are you mad
what has he done that makes these
horrible times
conversation for another day though
right folks let's get back to what steve
bannon said
he's betrayed donald trump he said
and this is because of course
they uh
worked a deal out mcconnell and chuck
schumer
to allow for the debt ceiling to be
raised that's that's the heart of all of
this at least steve bannon's gripe
so we got a higher debt ceiling right so
the u.s doesn't default on their debt
and according to bannon that's a
betrayal of trump
a betrayal of trump
you know the
old retired guy who's sitting down there
in florida playing golf he has been
betrayed
he he's not in power steve
so i don't know exactly what you're so
mad about betraying donald trump because
the man doesn't have a job he's
he's retired
but again
mitch mcconnell donald trump and now of
course steve bannon been in this feud
trump is trying to back
republicans for senate two of them have
pledged if i get in the office
i'm gonna kick
mcconnell out of his leadership position
trump is encouraging other republicans
to do it and so far not a single sitting
republican has signed on to this idea
of kicking mitch mcconnell out of his
leadership position let me explain why
but to explain why i got to read a
little bit more about what bannon said
here
here's what your legacy will be
people are going to throw up in their
mouth
you have betrayed the republican party
you've betrayed the movement you're only
there because of trump you never had any
loyalty
the man
who's been representing the people
of kentucky in the united states senate
since i was two years old
so since the 1980s the early 1980s
he's only there because of trump steve
no
you've said a lot of dumb things in your
life and that might actually be one of
the dumbest
mitch mcconnell doesn't owe any of his
success and let's be honest it has been
a success for him to donald trump
like literally none of it
mitch mcconnell's legacy is not going to
be people throwing up in their mouths
unless of course they're on the left
because his legacy is packing the courts
with these corporatist judges
his legacy is tax cuts for the wealthy
his legacy is obstructing any kind of
forward progress for the united states
of america
none of which
he owes to donald trump
he did it under reagan
he did it under h.w bush
he did it under george w bush
it wouldn't matter who the republican
president was mitch mcconnell was one of
the guys calling the shots the entire
time
and when he had democratic presidents
clinton obama and now biden
he's been leading the charge for
obstruction none of which again he owes
to donald trump
so bannon you're delusional if you think
that mitch mcconnell owes anything to
donald trump if anything it's the other
way around
mitch mcconnell's good at politics and i
will give him credit for that he is a
horrible person in my opinion who has
enacted some horrible policies and
blocked some great ones
but when it comes to being a republican
who knows how to do things mitch
mcconnell there's no one better than him
and that is literally the only praise i
will ever give for mitch mcconnell